staying in Germany and Chancellor Angela
Merkel welcomed Ukraine's recently
elected president Baldomir zalenski in
Berlin but why a military band played
their national anthems in very hot
weather the German leader seemed unwell
shaking at times but when she walked by
the guard of honor the trembling seemed
to have stopped Merkel said later at a
press conference that she had some water
to drink and was feeling much better
zalinsky is in the German capital for
discussions on bilateral issues on the
Minsk peace process to resolve Ukraine's
tensions with Russia let's talk to our
correspondents in Berlin we have a
political correspondent Emma chance and
in Kiev we have DJ Abuse and Nick
Connolly and one let me start with you
first of all we saw these pictures of
chance the angular Messi not looking
very well do we know how she is now well
she certainly seemed after words to feel
much better but as seen earlier on today
while the two national anthems were
playing were actually was actually quite
impressively so Chancellor Angela Merkel
shaking and she was visibly trying to
contain the situation as she stood under
the Sun is quite warm here in Berlin
which could explain why she felt unwell
now according to DPA News Agency it
isn't the first time that the German
leaders suffered from such a health
incident and worried journalists where
we journalists asked her in the press
conference after her meeting with
Vladimir as a renske how she was feeling
in his what she had to say to reassure
people I've drunk at least three glasses
of water which I apparently needed
feared so now I'm doing very well they
would so Chancellor motley feeling much
better their dehydration obviously seems
to be the problem Nick in Kiev what is
the significance of Ukraine's new
president's visit to Berlin why is he
here well I'm rich I think first and
foremost this was a chance for both of
them to take a look at each other and to
really get to know each other
this level in politics people have
mostly come across each other at some
event or other but in the case of
szalinski their real outsider someone
who only really entered politics a
couple of months ago there hadn't been a
meeting previously there was lot of
head-scratching in berlin when he won
that landslide victory in April's
election who is this guy is he someone
who can do real politics beyond
electioneering and belong beyond his
obvious talent for speaking to voters so
that was really first and foremost but
there are also real matters of points of
difference between Berlin Kiev
despite the relationship being very good
and there being lots agreement on lots
of other issues there is the issue of
the North stream to pipeline that Russia
is building to Russia something that
Ukraine says will undermine its energy
security that's something that continues
to be built despite Ukrainian concerns
as a let's give very much reiterating
the criticism that had come from his
predecessor also about that pipeline
then there's the issue of sanctions
Chancellor Merkel sticking firm to them
but increasingly loud voices in Germany
now saying that it's time to end those
sanctions against Russia since they
haven't been able to force Russia to
change its behavior I think use
important to remember here these are two
leaders who really couldn't be much more
different in terms of temperament and
style and this was really an opportunity
for them to show that despite those
differences they can work together and
try to push for some progress on peace
talks in Donbass and Emma what is
Germany hoping from this visit with
valdi Messalonskee well just as Nick
commonly said in Kiev those three that
both leaders were getting to know one
another but at the press conference
after the meeting they talked for about
an hour and angle America made clear
that the Western sanctions would only be
lifted against Russia
if Ukraine's sovereignty was restored
she said I quote as long as there is no
progress on this front of sanctions I
cannot be lifting at the section
sanctions related to Crimea can only
been be lifted if Crimea returns to
Ukraine end quote so she made a very
firm very firm statement in favor of
Ukraine's sovereignty and I think that's
what we can take away from today's
meeting with volunteers Aaron ski rod
and Nick in Cuba Germany is very
keen to see progress on the minsk peace
process watch kenya Lenski offer on that
well i'm richer it's pretty tough to see
where he goes from here he has said that
bringing peace to the east of ukraine is
his priority stopping ukrainian soldiers
dying he said in his big inaugural
speech would be his main aim as leader
but you know to be totally honest about
this he can bring new faces to the table
he can bring in new negotiators he can
try and change the tone that really has
seen these negotiations run into a into
a basically into a cul-de-sac in the
last few years with barely any progress
made he's talked about
confidence-building moves like small
exchanges of prisoners from both sides
to really improve the tone between the
two sides but beyond that this is not
something strictly that's really in his
hands to give a lot of this will be
decided in the Kremlin and the Kremlin
support for those pro-russian
separatists that are facing off against
the Ukrainian government and beyond that
even if the Lenski want to make big
concessions to the other side it's not
clear that Ukrainian society will let
him do that
hundreds of thousands of people a force
in that conflict thousands have died and
there are a lot of people who are very
vocal here who will be watching and
won't be allowing him to do anything
which they think in dangers Ukraine's
interests right Nick Connolly in Kiev
and DW political correspondent Emmanuel
Shaz thank you both very much for your
perspectives